Consider looking at yourself in the mirror.
Have you ever looked so closely and intensely
at your reflection that you start to become
aware of the details and complexities of your
skin that you otherwise never notice?
Have you ever stared at your reflection until
you no longer recognize it?
What is it that you are looking at it?
Is it YOU?
Are YOU your face?
Are YOU your brain?
Do you control entirely what it is that you
are looking at?
If it decides to grow hair, do you have any
say in the matter?
You can cut or shave the hair, but it will
still continue to grow.
What you are staring at is, therefore, not
entirely yours.
It belongs partly to the collective entity
of life.
What you are staring at is part stranger to
you, and you must make friends with it or
it will become your worst enemy.
As humans, we are just as unconscious as we
are conscious.
For everything that we can control and understand
about ourselves, there is an equal amount
that we cannot.
We sit somewhere in the middle, between complete
consciousness and complete unconsciousness,
and this is arguably where all human conflict
stems from.
Smart enough to understand the notion of complete
control and perfection, but not smart enough
to achieve it.
We have yet to become what we conceive and
expect of ourselves.
But no matter how hard we try, at this point
in evolution, we will never be of complete
and perfect omniscience.
We all know this, yet it still seems that
we constantly expect perfection from our self
and the rest of the world.
But we must not depend our purpose and excitement
in life on whether or not we can control and
perfect everything.
Our sense of purpose and excitement is found
in the way that our imperfection keeps life
fresh, uncertain, and inspiring.
Only those who can posses the conscious abilities
of the human, but not be tormented by the
conscious inabilities of the human, will become
into what it truly means to be human in the
first place.
We must learn how to separate the desire of
perfection and the expectation of perfection.
It is admirable and very human to strive for
perfection, but it is equally human to not
achieve it.
We must remember this as we travel through
life, so that we do not become disheartened
and void of wonder and enjoyment.